hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space okay right to it click the button
we're just gonna fire our way down here
and then you don't see me what do you
think you're talking about are those
exploding barrels they are I didn't even
know there were exploding barrels in
this game uh man that's a lot of enemies
you'd think that I would be dead by now
if this was real life but obviously this
is not ergo I'm doing just fine job
man it's kind of hard the aiming on dead
space has always been a little bit wonky
how come on just one more
well I don't care what how Jesus oh yeah
okay let me down let me down let me down
much easier to fire from here go you
don't you don't got nobody in fact you
don't got a head yeah okay anyway so now
that we're down here we're trying to get
Dannic we're trying to kill and I'm
trying to get revenge for what he did to
Ellie what's up hey I want that safety
guard what the hell's our Savior ah once
again I've got way too many of these
things okay you to drop how do I drop
there we go
drop thank you no that's not right thank
you I don't need a okay apparently I did
oh not one of these things this is my
least favorite of the puzzles if you
guys could tell all right
oh gosh brain not working Oh piss ah oh
lordy okay go go go go go go go go go go
go thank you
ah pest ah Oh
Oh God
Oh God okay there we go seriously you
guys may not know or it may not seem
like it's that complicated but trying to
figure out how to move the keyboard in
the mouse it would be much easier with
joypads but with the keyboard on the
mouse it's like a living nightmare it's
horrifying that's what it is
okay yes bench turn it off oh oh I get
it
turn it off because because the machine
is actually what's preventing
convergence everyone's going crazy
saying turn it off so okay I get it I
get it I get it
okay need to sell
thank you I need ammo I do not need this
money stasis packs I'm not that good
with stasis anyway so it wouldn't do me
anything but I do need ammo surprisingly
I've never really needed ammo before I
got tungsten bars we're good on all
fronts okay we're good I don't have time
to worry about anything else because
Dannic a scavenging bot waiting for me
at the bench what are you talking about
I was just at the bench come on Dan X
about to destroy the whole universe
let's go let's go let's go okay okay
okay okay all right all right all right
okay all right let's go let's go let's
go
and what does make you wonder who
originally created the markers in the
first place I mean they had to be crated
by someone right
[ __ ] yeah destroy the head like
traditional zombies here no Emma these
heads are tough I wonder what happened
to the conglomeration weird the really
freaky monsters that were prevalent in
the first and second dead space you know
the big lanky ones that went you shot
and killed they split apart into their
individual pieces those are the freaky
ones
I'll become a buddy hmm yeah I'm still
alive [ __ ] not like you're gonna be
soon
amazing the range that this shotgun is
ineffective at
ah it's hard to hit those guys they're
exploding oh those guys one of those
easy I guess I should have been paying
attention a bit more they seemed to be
around me wah hell are you
Oh get dive right into a met smart oh
thank you
Oh what's this I finally get to fight a
brute what's been a while since I saw
one of you no you stay I might have not
wanted to sell those stasis packs how
you get a shotgun blasted or something
up Oh
ha ha [ __ ] what do you think of me now
huh huh can't catch me
hey look it's another one
okay yeah jump right on its head
did I kill it I finally killed it by
jumping right on top of it may not dead
I can't kill it there's just two of them
you a-hole they soaked up hey Isaac must
be pretty dang fat to have killed one of
those things by landing on it
Boop so pro by the way I totally plan
that I just I'm just that throw the
javelin gun I hated the jab
yeah what do we got Billy
Thank You Gavin Len gun never really I I
know it's shot and then you could
alternate fire to make it shock but it
never really seemed to work for me
I might as well just stick to throwing
spikes off of the dead ones
taking good progress you think I could
just take the elevator banana elevators
for [ __ ]
and if there's one thing I know about
dicing carcass it I am no [ __ ] that's
doesn't look good huh Dodge oh it's a
gouge
god I'm so pro can't believe how pro I
am it's ridiculous even okay why can't I
go sideways I don't matter bro ah best
man whoo that's Purdy I make a good
thumbnail right there who got spun up
into him status ha ha
yeah like a boss
Oh Oh I'm a shitty oh there we go
how nice comfy snow where does everyone
all day issac wark she shot the rest
then ray liotta reinforcements but how
do they reach us we can open the
ventilation systems from in here
the drop ships oh it's on now they know
they're afraid already he's here he's
headed to the machine can you reach him
I'm trying to find a way into the city
we're gonna meet up on the way yeah the
city a that did say that it was an alien
city so I'm guessing this is the remnant
city of one of the previous species that
was subjected to the terrors of the
marker to be a little overdramatic about
it but everyone knows that's what I'm
all about overdramatic system
yeah we're doing pretty good so far I
don't think I need anything I don't
think I need anything I'm good to go
let's just wait a minute haha artifact
I heard that you get a special suit if
you get all the artifacts let's see all
sorts of goodies Tech's log
let's read dr. Earl Serrano the cranium
of the species contains six holes eats a
passage leading to a resonance chamber
not unlike our own nasal cavity that
when air is blown through the holes it
passes through a phone phonic membrane
that then vibrates and modulates a sound
by opening closing okay this is how they
talk why is this important is highly
unlike this speaks we would need a
pronunciation guide for its own language
in fact it appears to have been added as
an afterthought da blah blah whomever
discovered their world notation was left
for us to speak from then speak to them
from beyond the grave okay so that's how
they understood the alien language and
actually it appears that dr. Serrano
that's what controls the markers it's
the end state of the screegit
or rather it would have been you see the
natives of this planet constructed a
machine that froze the moon in mid
formation but it wasn't enough even half
formed the moon's marker signal speaks
to the markers back home and it doesn't
end there there is a network of brethren
moons spanning the stars as each one
completes it connects to this network
making them aware if this moon should
complete its brothers will all come
looking for food but there is hope the
natives never finished configuring the
machine it wasn't meant to merely freeze
the moon it was meant to destroy ah the
Codex it is the key to unlocking this
machine and reconfiguring it follow my
trail into the heart of the machine and
end this nightmare okay Carver did you
hear that the machine can crush the moon
Oh what softly configured what about
Derek stopping Dannic won't be enough we
need to get that codex back it's the key
to reconfiguring the machine serrano's
lock the passage using some kind of
alien glyphs I'm gonna look for a way to
bypass look okay this was why I was
important okay okay okay
there we go how's easy I was like
probably the easiest that's probably
easiest puzzle I've ever had in this
game or maybe I'm just so smart that
it's like not even a problem for me hey
open up oh hello
my god
[ __ ]
this must be ground zero
and that must be the machine
so I guess it's it huh yeah this is it
I need you to promise me something if I
don't make it you'll get this done right
we'll get this done Carver you and me
yeah but I don't
I helped get us this far
and that's close enough for all this to
count right count for what
all the bad I've done must shut up
Carver you're a good man
highly needed my son
wrecked my family Isaac I killed Santos
is that what a good man does good men me
just don't always end up doing well
I'm sorry about le man
me too
this way problem took stamp it's not you
late turn it back now right so give that
codex
oh right well that was a highly
emotional interlude there I just need to
grab all the rest of the stuff
uh-huh I guess I can see like towards
the end of the game it's more apparent
and where all the co-op stuff would lie
I mean obviously this would be run
together because as oh I can't go that
way apparently as brothers in arms and
really and you know all the emotions so
many emotions feelings I had all
feelings you are unbelievably hard to
kill are you aware about the update do
you know about the moon do you know what
it is both of the miraculous ecosystem I
assume it's a live deck it's hungry and
isn't alone if you turn off the Machine
you'll set it free and then kid and all
its brothers final markers find us and
wipe us out how can you presume to know
its intention you fear because you don't
understand it
daddy care me out daddy are you
listening to me
[ __ ] I love the way that the
voice actor for Isaac Clark says
[ __ ] it's the [ __ ] every time
like when he's stomping he says it - ha
that's a bomb I did why did I just do
that how did I know that I would do that
he's just it's very elegant the way says
it brutal but elegant mother [ __ ] I
can't I can't even come close
mother hey man burger shoot them who's
gonna shoot me you guys really you think
you can good job not shooting me way to
fail ha ha
I'm Barry Manilow Lula all right give me
that
I think up let's blow up another bomb I
guess hey sis is that a little flame or
exploding thingy on the front that's
that's adorable
hi Carver how's going buddy Bhoomi oh I
need another one oh okay oh man the hey
is that an artifact shut up shut up I
got it I can only move so fast with this
maybe I could like chuck it over there
and get it later
ah pass it fell off the mountain um an
idiot get me another one give me another
one of your magic exploding devices
apparently I can't throw it without it
falling all over the place so here I me
and err slowly we're in a hurry Isaac um
it's very delicate don't don't brush me
don't rush me man don't don't rush I'm
trying to work as fast as I can
you're just standing there like a loony
ah
oh hi danik hey how's it going he why
don't you guys do something there we go
Oh
ah okay over where once again we are
separated by days deus ex machina whoa
hi these are the things that used to be
the babies the really creepy babies once
again they have changed them
dr. boom no it's gone down boom come on
thank you this gun is awesome I
sometimes forget that this gun actually
does a lot of damage because I usually
use it to fight a lot of enemies but
instead I guess I'll go that way later
instead it also pumps out the DPS like a
mouse and I guess those are the evolved
forms of these other aliens and those
guys are big seriously so just one of
them what okay I heard that
don't know if I got it perfectly okay
yeah I got it
it's nice when the subtitles read the
exact text for me that's awfully nice
whoa fancy now do I detect a hint of
Aztec inspiration hello
I wonder how much of the population of
this race went insane Oh obviously quite
a bit it's awfully dark in here Oh oh
wait where am I going well I'm going up
here we go
haven't been in zero gravity for a while
like since the beginning of the game see
you don't whoa what I don't see anything
what does I'm going for that high ball
okay where am I going where am I going
I'm going that way but I can't seem to
go that way like something's blocking me
from going up what the hell I'm trying
where are you where are you where are
you where are you where the Frick are
you oh there you are Jesus
okay we're like being highly tablet here
and I cannot see where the frickin
enemies I'm trying to get through here
there we go okay I'm through no I'm not
I just went in a circle where are you
for the hell are you oh there you are
just fall over and die thank you okay so
now that we're okay through here let's
see if I can actually go this way No
well this is bad well this is actually
quite very very bad I cannot go through
here
what's the dare we go Saros too fat to
fit sideways apparently where are you I
hear you I just don't see you oh there
you are no thank you
gimme a go I can I land now please dear
gravity in this confined space really
messes okay yeah once again that's
really can be hit like Chewbacca
language Wookiee Wookiee leg don't get
on my case get me dammit re-fall piece
of junk
I miss that other one - I need a frickin
bench earn enough benches supercharged
RTK capacity but hurt like hell
what about stasis what I think it's in
hands to try let me know whoa ha how did
it how did I know that that worked like
that Isaac Clark just too smart for his
own good he knows everything and I
wonder why the alien technology was able
to or maybe there was a human technology
that was used previously
and he's encountered it before I don't
know and why would it hurt like hell
oh no to salt the bench a bench bench
how do I need another compact standard
frame thank you thank you thank you
thank you once cavity bot Thank You
Billy thank you baby I have lots of
materials now I actually have enough
ration seals to buy another pack hey not
bad oh yeah yeah all right
ah let's get rid of one II shoot and
there we go we're good we're good
climbing up what's up there I seem to be
going a lot of ways that I would think
that I would be going before but I don't
know this is all so confusing what is
that oh those are statues okay I thought
those are actually like more skeletons
of these big old things up
you know I would like to live in and
will not live in this world it's like
you know people say video games they
want to live in a world that baby game
is but in the video games usually the
worlds are in such times of crisis that
everything is about to be destroyed all
the time and you things are freaky but I
would love to live in the age of
technology that this is because the TK
stuff is really really cool to me
incredible isn't it I call this the
promenade one of the many conduits
straight to the heart of the machine is
that without the codex I can only
speculate
to be made I will leave the monolith on
this plateau to just that by standing on
the special disk shaped area of the
floor I've discovered I can use my
Kinesis motion in a boosted capacity
okay hieroglyphics on the wall behind me
indicate that one configuration will
open the machine
another will enact any changes to the
internal programming once you get it
open and have followed all of my
research you will need to return here to
enact the final stage okay I know that
was dr. Serrano but apparently I need to
do something before I can actually
effect these so huh
oh I see these oh these are what you're
talking about
oh I supposed to view the hieroglyphics
that's right um is it something here I
don't see anything don't see anything
there oh I get it these are the
hieroglyphics on the walls oh okay so
one opens it one changes the programming
so if I go up one yeah I'm looking at
the big giant wall why would you assume
that I would turn around to look at this
stuff behind me opposite of where the
voice is coming from okay so one of
these does something the other does
something else yeah what does that do
I don't know what I'm doing I'm just a
stupid human no what is that
yay this isn't the city Carver
oh this this is the machine oh okay
you're the engineer how do we fix it
well follow serranos clues or
reconfigure the machine i just opened a
conduit to the heart of the city uh-huh
there's a control center for the Codex
that's where it'll be okay be there now
what is the other configuration do I'm
just curious I'm gonna test it out for a
second here see it's oh oh come on let
me at least see what the other thing
does maybe the other thing blew up the
entire place baby I don't want to figure
out what that does okay just moving
forward lucky that I'm still alive add
either Clark so Lucky's still alive a
thousand times I would also like to live
in the non Reaper infested universe of
Mass Effect that would be a cool
universe because they got space magic
space magic okay hi
if I shoot you really quickly
you spread out those things that's weird
nope and
whoa what's that buy me another one ah
ah go away you're dead have anything I
can throw this guy okay there's a bunch
of a Mama's gonna go this way
please tell me this isn't like a field
that I can ah not the babies
okay I'm flying now moochers awesome the
gal Friedrich Clark frickin Iron Man I'm
good
I love these sequences there weren't
enough of these type of sequences in
Dead Space 2 or dads made three for that
matter cuz this is awesome
I love it that was amazing
I want to do more okay I'll tell you
these at least these doors are easy I
like it when things are easy hello Billy
thank you alright I did not see an auto
se but I hope there's one soon cuz I'm
running short of yeah
hey hang on let me see him what the hell
that's awesome
it was awesome no you don't oh no you
don't supercharged stasis is amazing
head splosions all around thank you very
much
how about it Harold should chillax for a
bit seems like they also increases
damage done to them
if I can just spot heads left and right
here nip nip nip Hank oh this is fun I
like it when they give me interesting
game mechanics to work with okay was
that all of them - reload - damage
hell's to the yeah oh I hear you whining
and complaining about your recent death
why don't you just suck it up stasis
monster well it's kind of stasis you dad
you can't be statist okay anyway I'm
actually just about all out of time here
so I will leave it here and if I didn't
checkpoint soon I'll just make my way
back here I've done it before so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos and I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
China
Oh
knock on door
bud
Oh
yeah